number one thing that I'm most concerned
about about going into Ted lasso season
three is if Keely and Roy are going to
stay together how much the fans be
worried
um
[Laughter]
great response all I can say is I'm a
huge fan of Roy Keating myself and I'm
as I'm as worried as you are but we'll
see
we'll see so we're gonna need a lot of
wine and just hoping right yeah
are you are you surprised at how much
people are just in love with this couple
uh I'm surprised by all aspects of of
people's uh engaging with the show it's
really wonderful I mean look it's very
very the truth is it was incredibly
special to do and me and Juno really uh
kind of it it felt magical while we were
making it and it was like building this
this relationship that felt very real
and loving and complicated and adult and
yeah I mean I'm as invested As You Are
well we know that Roy Ken's favorite
word rhymes with duck how often do you
think you say that word in each episode
this season this season trying to notch
it up uh oh probably yeah episode you
look in it I know how if an episode's 30
minutes I'm I'm looking at least two a
minute I'm open 60 or 60 60
68 69 per rep
really sound like it should just it's
just Rhythm Now isn't it like right it
doesn't really register it's just part
of a like a song
I love it it's it's like one of my
favorite Parts about your character is
it your mandate to up the ante when it
comes to swearing or is it just what the
fans want
uh no I I think it was uh
he just always was it was an early thing
we discussed is like
with the American Writers like if you're
making I say in England in football
there's gonna be a ton of swearing like
this isn't you can't pretend that's not
the world you know right you're just
staying true to the source yeah uh you
know season one was just as you've said
you know a surprise to your cast and
crew and how much everyone loved this
show and then season two it was the
exact same amount of love if not more
what has this show meant to you
personally especially when you were
filming season three
ah look the show completely changed my
life it's a real magical thing
uh and in terms of season three the the
difference we're making season three is
when we made the first two no one had
seen it yet so we didn't know
anyone's if we didn't know if anyone
would watch it we didn't know if anyone
would like it so the only the only thing
that made season three maybe I can't
speak for everyone this is only me
slightly challenging is you're aware of
what people
want or think about it and you have to
sort of quiet those voices in your head
and go Gotta stick to the story we have
to stick to the story that Jason always
had in his head and we We are following
through this thing and the the reality
is one of the things people liked about
the show is it was surprising to them so
we have to keep surprising them
otherwise
what do we do yeah I feel like Roy I
mean to be honest I feel like all the
characters but Roy especially always has
to learn a lesson each season or it's
something that as fans we figure out
he's kind of learning and has this
journey that he goes on what do you
think in season three is the biggest
lesson that Roy Kent has to learn
I think I think it would be I could
answer that but I worry it might spoil
things I'll give something away okay
okay yeah I think he he
it's this never-ending process of
becoming you know what I mean
that we'll we get to we we work through
something and then
it opens up a whole another level of
you know problems you have
inside yourself that need addressing
well that was good without spoiling too
much congratulations with everything and
I've already seen the first three
episodes that's what I was live to see
and it's so good oh great okay I said
this when season one came out Rebecca is
one of my favorite characters on any TV
show I love her so much yes you know
looking at Rebecca from season one to
season three she's evolved a lot yeah
I think so I definitely people like how
she's evolved I mean I really like her
through season three
what is your favorite thing about what
we get to see from Rebecca in season
three I got
I got that I love that is that fun for
you knowing like all this stuff we just
want to know more yeah there's one
moment that really made me laugh having
to do it and I can't wait for people to
see it that's exciting I was just
talking to Brett and he was telling me
you know when it came to season one and
season two while you were filming you
didn't even realize how popular the show
was going to become how much the critics
were going to love it so did it change
your experience going into filming
season three knowing all this now did he
tell you what what he and I said behind
the Craft Truck you know we have like
snacks and things no season one he and I
were like before today and it doesn't
matter now because it's ahead and it's
been successful but he and I behind the
Craft Truck were just like
I don't know what this show is do you
think people are gonna are they gonna
know what it is I mean is it a comedy is
it I was going I don't feel like I'm in
a comedy I feel like I'm crying quite a
lot
is amazing I'm gonna add we were both
like oh
I love that no it's just because you
know when you haven't seen it in the
edit and you don't know what what the
tone of it's gonna be you don't know or
you are paranoid about is your own
contribution and imposter syndrome
that's true well you already said it you
know there's crying this show is known
as a feel-good show but it really
tackles some serious issues how do you
juggle you know going from being funny
and then obviously dealing with those
serious moments well I feel like I'm
gonna struggle always if I don't get
something where I'm you know I'll be
like what do you mean I don't go from
making people laugh to making people
pull their eyes out in one sentence you
do so don't worry you do yeah exactly I
mean it's it's it's hard because
that is what my life has been for the
last three or four years has been in a
show that is so beautifully written you
know I know people talk about all our
performances but there are no
performances without the brilliant
writing in the first place so we are
absolutely spoiled out of our minds with
this writer's room
you know obviously Awards have been one
but what does a show like this in a
character like Rebecca how has all of
this changed you
um
I feel like it came into my life when I
needed a real calling card
um I wanted something that was was
something that you you look past
someone's appearance and and I would be
able to play layers of someone's
character that are sometimes
you know
unraveling and sometimes uh
knowing where where she's going I wanted
someone that that is how we all are like
having your great days and your bad days
and people who will pick you up in
between
I love that Rebecca also has the best
hair
nice hair I love your hair it's so great
um I'm obsessed with her hair
okay I thought I just I just didn't know
if that was like a meat thing or yeah
I'm glad you've noticed it yeah I'm
always like well because you have to be
very careful if you're playing this boss
it can't be like a Keeley hairdo
because keeley's you know wearing like
statement makeup statement hair whereas
Rebecca I like to to make her hair and
particularly her earrings yeah very
she's a very emotional dresser see some
days she's in a colder paler a more icy
look and more spiky earrings with a bit
more of a severe hairdo another day
she's a bit more
I know I love it okay well I'm getting
the wrap but I love season three they
let us see three episodes and I already
love it so thank you so much good good
thank you so much speak to you again
another time